Welcome to our data cleaning in Excel
tutorial this video will explore
essential techniques to transform messy
data into accurate and meaningful
insights from removing duplicates and
handling missing values to formatting
inconsistencies and error detection we
will guide you step by step throughout
the process learn how to efficiently
clean organize and standardize your data
using excel's powerful tools and
functions mastering data cleaning will
enhance your analysis and save you
valuable time let's dive in and unlock
the true potential of your data with
excel's data cleaning capabilities
before you get started if these are the
types of videos you would like to watch
then hit that subscribe button and the
bell icon to never miss any update from
Simply learn also if you are one of the
inspiring business analysts looking for
online training and graduating from the
best universities or a professional who
elicits to switch careers with business
analytics by learning from the experts
then try giving a short to Simply learn
postgraduate program in business
analysis that is from Purdue University
and in collaboration with IBM the course
link is mentioned in the description box
and you should navigate to the course
page where you can find a complete audio
of the program being offered without
further Ado over to our training experts
hey everyone so let's get started with
data cleaning in Excel
so without further Ado let's get
connected to excel where we have the
data set that we need to use to perform
the data cleaning process so right now
on my screen you can see a simple data
set which has details of students so we
have name gender data joining race or
authenticity parental level of Education
country project and their scores and
everything right so we might have to
perform some data analysis operations
and if you directly ingest this data
onto data visualization tools or any of
the analytical tools you might have some
discrepancies on the data which might
end up creating some discrepancies or
abnormalities on your data report right
so for example if you can see this
particular name section here we have
duplications and names so we have Jane
Smith entered for twice and in the
seventh row you can see there are some
blank spaces in the front of the image
in front of the name and you can also
see there is no gender specified in this
particular section right and if you also
pay some attention to detail in the okay
let's expand the columns perfectly first
yeah into the column where we have
country and city there are countries and
cities to every row but in a few places
we can see Planck cells again and again
here in the section of project completed
or not you also have some blank spaces
once again right and if you clearly
check at the dates column you have
different kind of dates right I don't
mean to say different data types I mean
to say we have one single data type that
is date but the way the dates are
written or represented as different if
you closely observe we have 0 4 0 4 2020
separate by hyphen in the next row you
have you can see that the date has been
separated by the you know dots and again
so so slowly somewhere we might have
backslash right so there are different
ways of representing the date so there
are some anomalies in the data which you
might have to clear and again if you
want to add some formula let's say you
have this students course and you wanted
to calculate the average score right
let's say average
and if you won't also wanted to decide
the uh you know class at which they have
achieved their uh degree right so that
can also be added here so it won't do
that and right so these are the few uh
problems that currently we have with our
data which need to be sorted so we will
be performing the data cleaning
operations one after the other right
let's quickly uh create a copy of this
data set so that uh as a bonus point we
will also do the same data cleaning
process in power query which can be a
lot more easier so right so let's
quickly uh create a copy of this
so before we get started with the power
query let's hear it from our Learners
about their success story after
graduating from the post graduation
program in business analytics from
Purdue University
I have always been passionate about
learning new things and improving my
teaching skills about five years ago I
realized that I have a gap in my
knowledge and to fill the Gap I need to
skill myself I chose imprilateral my
upskilling partner because of all it's
comprehensive curriculum and it's
connection with Urdu University hi my
name is Carlos vinares
I live in Lexington University of
Kentucky in the United States I am an
assistant professor at Midway University
and I hold a PhD in management human
resources and Leadership I decided to
opt for the post graduation program in
business analysis from Silver which has
helped me a lot to my professional and
personal life
I have been teaching having before I
moved to the United States years ago
I try to use Excel while teaching
research classes
but
since I only had the basic knowledge
about it and other business intelligence
tools it was very difficult for me at
the beginning but after completing this
class and learning how to use tools like
Excel Tableau power bi power query
problem I feel like it has been a total
game changer for me now I apply these
skills everywhere
which has also helped me a lot in my
yearly reviews I submitted all my
certificates to my university and based
on that my University plans to develop a
class focus on business analysis
starting in Fall 2023
and I am really excited
when I finally decide to go for an
online program I research a lot
and finally I chose simply learner and I
must say it has been a wonderful
experience
if you see how the business world is
changing now when you're Skilling
yourself is quite essential to keep up
with the change everything works on
numbers now data is more valuable and
important than ever so
I encourage you to keep learning
and keep growing now let's continue with
our query so why are we using power
query again so uh whatever the data
cleaning process that we are going to
perform is good upgrade extender because
uh if you are dealing with some
real-time data and if you are dealing
with some data which almost changes
every now and then then the data
cleaning process that which we are about
to do will be stagnated let's say for an
example we have the First Column as name
column as a requirement you might have
to let's say insert a new column here
and another new column here let's say we
have a requirement where your manager
says that he wants first name and last
name as separate right
first name and lastly
so let's begin with uh the first stage
right so that you have a better
understanding of what's the problem that
we have with this routine way of
cleaning our data right so firstly uh
let us
make our data look aesthetically correct
let's add some boundaries and all the
things that make it a little more better
looking right so the first one let's try
to split the first name and last name
right so here you can see the first name
is John Doe right so I'll be writing j o
h n
there you go and g-a-n-e right so when I
was about to type the first name you can
see something got highlighted right j o
h n
and again if I write Jane once again
and Michael right so it is able to
predict that something is about to be
coming out right Excel is able to
predict that uh there is something in
user's mind so maybe if it's that what I
think right you can see it automatically
has suggested me so it is trying to
understand what you want to do so that
particular feature of excel is called as
Flash Fill right right now you have
entered this first name and second name
right
uh you have entered first names and here
Gene once again
and let's try Michael and see you can if
I minimize the screen you can see uh it
is showing the entire data set right it
is splitting the first name of column A
from the entire data set just press
enter and you can see it has entered all
the first names until the last row right
just within one single press of an
entity so that particular feature of
excel is known as Flash Fill in Excel
now let us try the Flash Fill once again
by adding the second names of each and
every uh
student in the data set press enter
there you go now what was the problem
right Flash Fill works if the data is
stagnant it is a very fast and quickest
way to split data and you can also okay
let's try another different way as well
to split the data I am going to insert
two more columns with same names first
name and last name right now let's click
on the column select the column and go
to data and here we will have an option
called as
text to columns yes so here our data is
delimited with a comma so go to next we
have selected the delimited option over
here fixed width and delimited let's
also check the fixed worth one first
let's go with the limited one right so
here let's select comma because we have
comma and click on
okay
so it is splitting in the same row
itself it is also okay not a big problem
so it has split the first name and last
name automatically right so let's have
it over here
here and since we don't need this
particular column we can delete it
right so here you can see we have first
name and last name okay if I undo all
the process
right okay what I can do is
[Music]
Copic cells Here and Now split uh this
particular thing into column so that I
do have the original column as it is
right
I have it over here
so I'll delete this column now we have
both ways first is The Flash Fill one
this particular one is let me name it as
Flash
and this one as flash as well
right so that we have two different
methods where data got split from uh
first name to last name right so
what's the catch now let me change the
name in the original cell let me name it
as Tony
Stark
now you can see we used a split text to
columns in the first place that is this
particular one and Flash Fill in the
next option but when the data got
changed here
it is not representing in the same way
right it's not that catching the new
entry into the cell or original cell so
that is the problem with this particular
one will also solve it through Power
query so first step of cleaning uh text
is the split the columns that we did
okay and let's also check on a few more
anomalies which we had that is blank
spaces formulas Etc we'll also check
that one so so far we've finished with
the
text to columns and Flash Fill
now let's minimize the cell size again
back to normal
right and now let's try to
let's say remove these or okay let's try
to insert a new column here and since we
found that a few of the cells had Extra
Spaces over here let's try to remove
those Spaces by using the formula let's
say trend
equals to
trim function
and cell address
enter
so you can
extend the same formula throughout all
the rows and now you can see all the
extra blank spaces are being removed out
right and you can see uh previously when
we used the Flash Fill right so it is
having Extra Spaces
right you can see it retains the Extra
Spaces which we didn't need it so if I
expand the
sheet you can see
the extra blank space is what we had in
the original cell got retained in the
resultant cell as well right let's try
to avoid that so let's try to minimize
the cells back to the original size and
now you can conduct the same operation
where you can you know kind of eliminate
all the unnecessary cells
now we have the first name
and the last name
foreign
now comes it now let's try to eliminate
the duplicate records in our data set so
select all the data that you have on
your data and then data set go to data
and here you should be having an option
called remove duplicates you know you
it's very small and you just have to
check for the data tools group and in
the data tools group
select this particular icon which says
remote duplicates now at the last queue
based on what parameter
so let's give it one single parameter so
let's uncheck all the select all the
options give it to one single primary
key kind of thing so here we have name
so click on that or you can also give it
as the first name anything which is
which is unique for that particular
instance and since we don't have a
unique primary key I believe we have
each unique students here so I give you
the option called first name and based
on first name keep holding the unique
identities press on OK OK
so so far we are good with the data and
now we have the blank spaces right and
let's try to replace the gender column
first so wherever we have blank spaces
then there you can eliminate the
uh you know you can keep the space
filled with as others okay let's try to
do it
let's go to the original sheet before we
perform any of the operations
and here
select the entire range go to data Tab
and click on the option
from table range
so it has automatically selected the
range and click on my table has header
so that your power query window knows
that the first row is the headers right
click on OK and now we are on the pop-up
power query editor
so here you have the option to split the
column into first name and the second
name by delimiter and our delimiter is
comma
so let's say you have multiple
delimiters right so your name can be
John Doe and another name which is
separated by two commas here right so we
don't want that to be happening so if we
have three instances or more than two
instances of comma it will say create
two to three uh you know columns so we
don't want that so let's provide left to
most delimiter so once if it has
occurred then it's enough
right now we have the first name and
second name successfully registered and
on the right side you can see we have
query settings tab and applied steps tab
right here you can see each and every
action what we are doing is being
registered so that if you want to create
or if you want to run the same operation
once again you can just click on that
and it will apply it now here we have
different different dates right so let's
try to format the dates as well
into one single date format right click
and here you can see change type option
so here you can click on date so that
all the formats run into one single type
of format right and uh here
we have some null elements registered so
let's okay let's go back to gender
column and here let's try to replace all
the null values with others
so click on the replace values and here
type in small case or lowercase and
replace with others
now press ok so wherever it finds null
entry it will replace it as others now
coming back to the project column and
yeah the country and the city column
right so here as well so you can see all
the entries are of the students are from
different cities so it should be like
they are taking the course in remote now
that is the online course now wherever
you find null that should be the
students from the University as well
right so again press as null in
smaller case University student
or yeah
you can write it as daily scholar
means this particular student is going
to college every single day and the
remaining ones are taking up the course
through online
there you go
so we have daily Scholars wherever we
have null
right so that's it and now coming to
project so here in a few places we have
completed and in a few places we have
none and in a few places we have null so
wherever we have null it is an
indication that the project is still in
progress and in places where we have
none it means that that particular
student does not have to any projects or
projects are not related to that
particular course it can be anything
right so let's try to replace the values
once again wherever we have none let's
try to add it as in progress
okay
and
let's say we also want to split the
groups
so we can do that by split column by
number of characters
g r o u p five characters right so press
OK and now we have eliminated the first
five characters and separated the group
right so these are the groups which we
needed
and so far so good the data is clean so
we have our first name and second name
splitted the gender column sorted the
date data type has been sorted so we
have one single data type for all the
page and group has been separated and
some college so
yeah again this particular column if you
want to change something let's say
if you wanted to replace the values of
some college
to
you know
uneducated or something
something relevant which makes more
sense you can do that so it's done as
well and the fee structure is also
standard and Country City are also done
so wherever we had no data it's been
recorded as a daily scholar and progress
about the project is set and the marks
achieved in AIM LDL everything is sorted
now that we have the cleaner data all
you can do is just click on the home
button and you can choose the option
close and load
right now you have the data loaded onto
your Excel spreadsheet
what's this and
adjust the column width
now you can calculate the average
all the three rows
and return
apply to all the rows
and again your if condition
if
this value is greater than
then student is
written here
has passed the test
else
it's okay
now you can apply the same to all the
rows and done now your data is clean so
that's how you can do data cleaning in
Excel so if you have any queries
regarding any of the topics covered in
the session or if you require the
resources that we used in this session
then do let us know in the comment
section below and our team of experts
will be more than happy to resolve all
the queries at the earliest
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and of Skilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here